[Music]
let me say
uh first of all very briefly what i
intend to do
in this talk i want to
um put a little bit of pressure on the
concept of
individualism in my talk today i want to
look at how
it arose and the role it played in what
is often thought of as early western
modernity
say in the 17th century i'm going to ask
how it was thought to apply or not to
apply
to the world outside that western
modernity
then i'm going to turn to a pair of
concepts that i'm broadly going to label
the self and the person
as two ideas about the human being that
are found in pre-modern
indian thought and i'm going to use
that pair to put a little bit more of a
critical
pressure on the notion of the individual
and i want to end by suggesting that
individualism
has a great many problems when it comes
to
talking about human beings and the way
they actually
live as well as perhaps the way they
ought to
so what is this concept of individualism
a dominant account of it goes something
like this
that through changes in the
intellectual climate that marked the
emergence
of modernity in europe sometime around
the period of the
late 16th and through into the 17th
century
following on from the renaissance
you saw this idea of the
human being as each
distinctive and driven by
distinctive motivations having
a particular kind of interiority
that is to say an inward
awareness of their own subjectivity
their own
experiences and their own narratives
about themselves
this idea it is often claimed arose
in distinction to
more diffuse senses of who we were
in pre-modern west and in
other parts of the world even at the
time of the 17th century
this idea of individualism is then
seen as justifying
a particular narrative in the political
history of europe
it simultaneously seeks to
secure the foundations of
liberal democratic thought and the
origins
of a liberal polity in which
individuals were seen as the way
in which individualism was seen as the
way in which
human beings should be conceived of
in relation to one another and the
primacy
of that individual's
own motivations interest and self-worth
was supposed to feed into a larger
contract
by which society was able to flourish
at the same time as this notion of
individualism
which was thought to generate such
related notions as
tolerance and equality between
human beings in the society was being
propagated and developed
it was also being used in an extremely
unequal hegemonic intolerant way
in the justification of european empires
because it was claimed and it's
continued to be claimed into the 20th
and even to the 21st century
that societies in the rest of the world
which did not go through this process
of uh individualization
which accompanied the birth of western
modernity
was seen as in some sense lacking
that particular self-conception
that allowed them to have the same
uh interactions and therefore the same
rights as european individuals
and even after empire passed
we still continue to have this idea
that individualism was a particular
characteristic
of western human beings
so for example in the literature on the
sociology of
india we have had many
uh influential notions of how to think
about
the indian human one idea was
that whereas the western
individual western human being of
modernity was an
individual the indian and particularly
the hindu
person was actually always
thinking hierarchically homo
hierarchicus
and therefore thought of himself
and herself in terms of a location
within an hierarchy now that
basically meant that you could say if
hindus and by extension other indians
in south asia thought in terms of
who was about them and who were beneath
them
then obviously it would not matter to
them
whether they were being ruled by
emperors in
india or emperors in london
you would simply have a justification
for the continuation of a hierarchical
self-conception of the human being in
which
there was a new set of rulers
and that as i said continued to be
thought of as a structural analysis of
human beings in india
even after the end of the british empire
another kind of idea
an american idea was that whereas
in the west you had an individual in
india
we needed to think of human beings as
dividuals
that is to say always in
connection to others
and i remember this is a little bit
autobiographical but
it does set me on this larger
intellectual trajectory
when i was studying these ideas
say in my uh late teens
i would really ponder on what exactly
it meant for me to be
not an individual in the way these
self-assured
french and british and american
anthropologists
were it could clearly not be the case
that
i couldn't withdraw into my own thoughts
and be silent apart from the very
phenomenological truth that i did so
the vast literatures of india going back
to
1500 bce were replete with examples of
interiority
of an extremely sophisticated sort so it
wasn't as if there wasn't a literary
cultural narrative
and it wasn't as if phenomenologically
it was impossible to think i
or anybody else not western could think
of themselves as separate
at this as distinct as having access
to ideas about themselves thoughts and
feelings
that were unique and not in fact
simply shared or floating in
relationality with others
and there was also a much trickier
question of how
exactly this concept of individualism
was supposed
to function if indeed it was
tied to the
necessary conditions for a liberal
democracy
in which concepts of equality for
example
and freedom of social action were
possible
then was it the case that say when the
impeccably liberal democratic indian
constitution
was formed that at least the mothers and
fathers of the indian constitution
if not the hundreds of millions of
people
in india suddenly became western
individuals
what kind of a psychological flip had
been thrown
moreover if individualism was
a continuous presence an invention
of a particular type of subjectivity in
western modernity
then what exactly was happening
in totalitarian regimes of the west or
indeed authoritarian ones like
spain or portugal or greece which did
not even become liberal democracies
until the 1970s
so we start having all these different
kinds of
questions about what individualism could
possibly be
so i hope i'm able to at least establish
a prima facie case
that individualism cannot be taken
seriously
as a description of the phenomenology of
subjectivity
it cannot be taken seriously as
a kind of historically specific
inauguration of a way of being human
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas